[Music]
I'm Jeff Glor from CBS this morning
Saturday today we have a show chock-full
of science that really has it all coffee
wine outer space and mummies what more
could you want
first up Dana Jacobson story that takes
us from a coffee genome to a cold brew
that doesn't use beans at all the main
goal today is to illustrate the
principle of conservation of mass bill
Wriston part isn't your average chemical
engineering professor for today we're
gonna be doing a whole bunch of brews in
the mr. coffee is the same amount of
water every time okay but then
systematically vary the mass of the
coffee grounds in his introduction to
chemical engineering class the design of
coffee students get to discover the
science inside a cup of joe and then
Part B this is real exciting we get to
do our first roast are you guys excited
about that yeah okay cool right
ristin part started the class in 2013 as
a freshman seminar the idea came to him
during what else a coffee break with a
colleague we were drinking coffee one
day thinking about how to improve our
engineering labs and she suggested that
idea why don't we have our students take
apart a mr. coffee drip brewer and I
thought oh my gosh why don't we make a
whole class about coffee
the class that started with just 18
students is now attended by two thousand
a year its popularity was highlighted a
few years back in a campus poll one of
their questions was what is the best
general education class and number one
was the design of coffee
number two is introduction to human
sexuality and number three was
introduction to beer brewing and so now
we like to say that at UC Davis coffee
is better than beer and sex it's a good
selling point for a lot of people it is
what we didn't anticipate was how much
interest there was from the industry and
they came to us and said hey you know we
need research there are a lot of
unanswered questions about coffee and
coffee faces a lot of issues and we
would love to partner with somebody in
academia UC Davis is well known for its
agricultural research in fields like
beer brewing and viticulture or wine
growing they actually have a vineyard
right on campus and so one of our big
goals is to make UC Davis an
international location of excellence to
create an academic talent pipeline to
support the coffee industry they've
already built a coffee center with a
prototype pilot roastery run by the
former head roaster at Blue Bottle
coffee a brewing and espresso laboratory
and a dedicated sensory lab in all there
are about 35 professors teaching courses
on everything from food science to
global social change in coffee cultures
1500 to present why do we need somebody
who knows how to do these things
anything that helps the confidence tree
produce better cups of coffee of higher
quality to increase demand helps not
only people here in the United States
but also there's a tremendous number of
people around the world who live in
developing countries whose livelihood
depends on coffee and so there's about a
hundred million people who make a living
by picking coffee one of the existential
threats to their livelihoods and our
cups of coffee is climate change it's a
huge concern there are lots of
discussions right now about whether
we'll have coffee in 30 years three
years ago UC Davis had a breakthrough
that could have a profound impact on
coffees survival when one Medrano and
Allen Van dines became the first
geneticists to create a reference genome
for a coffee bean for the
a person what does that mean when you
say there's no genome - right there was
no reference genome so there's no book
that tells me what is the sequence and
the genes in the copy genome okay and
that was very surprising to me because
being an industry that is 20 billion
dollar industry 2.4 million cups of
coffee every year and there's no genome
sequence when most crops have a sequence
why do we need the genomes for plants
like this it's a tool in plant breeding
it's a second most traded commodity in
the world but nobody's looking at it at
the plant level the pair honed in on C
Arabica the beam behind 70% of worldwide
consumption coffee has grown almost
exclusively outside of the United States
but ban dines a Medrano picked a Geisha
variety grown in Goleta California from
the good land organics farm we first
featured nearly three years ago also
basically you take Leafs of coffee of a
coffee plant right and this leaves a
coffee plants are macerated and you
extract DNA from the cells inside the
leaves okay and then you create a
collection of DNA fragments well we
ended up putting together was 1.2
billion base pairs so pieces of DNA
they're not a hundred percent in order
but they're in a very good shape the
goal is to breed a plant that can grow
at higher altitudes and fight diseases
like rust we say this all the time but
the coffee bean is it's magical outside
of academia the Seattle start up at Tomo
Coffee is taking the exact opposite
approach to coffee research food
scientists jarett's stop forth and his
co-founder and eke like want to make
coffee without the bean they call it
molecular coffee we talk about how when
he told me he wanted a hack coffee that
it blew my mind but it really did it
always gets everyone just imagining like
what is that how does that work ship it
off just yellow Otomo mixes plant-based
agricultural byproducts and caffeine
that when combined mimics actual coffee
down to the aroma and flavor the company
which launched last February on
Kickstarter has raised 2.5 million
dollars in venture capital we joke
around that this is like the $10,000 cup
of
right now but as we scale our production
will see our costs drop pretty
dramatically in which we should be able
to make coffee that is great tasting
that is actually cheaper to produce than
coffee today a Tomo plans to roll out
its cold brew coffee later this year as
it waits for patent approval while UC
Davis has made the Arabica genome
publicly available to anyone why not
make money off of it the basic knowledge
of the reference genome it's really an
opportunity for many scientists for many
people in different parts of the world
to benefit and produce great coffees
from it and that's the ingenuity this is
pre competitive research is a good way
of looking at it we're a public
institution and the idea is let's raise
the bar for everybody
Medrano who's now retired from the
university is a co-founder of fringe
coffee with jay [ __ ] of good land
organics this is our greenhouse this
plant right here is one SS geisha yeah
this is exactly the one that was
sequence this is a unique hybrid you
know that is resistant to frost this
coffee has 40% less caffeine the midday
coffee again not too tired but it has a
very floral day exquisite flavor when
the aroma is fantastic I would say this
is an all-day drinking coffee it's
delicious really delicious UC Davis is
also doing some research with the wine
industry in Napa Valley we'll have that
story after the break
if you love a good Cabernet Sauvignon
this next story is for you it is about
grapes from Northern California climate
change in scientific research here's
Jamie yuccas while a red wine should be
aged in barrels
these Cabernet grapes are dying on the
vine
Andy Beck Stouffer has been growing
grapes for some of the biggest names in
California wine country since the early
1970s
how much cab do you drink a day
breakfast lunch or dinner but he's
concerned about his future harvest the
big deal is the erratic nature that we
have with climate here we have bugs we
never heard of we have diseases we never
heard of before we have we've changed
the way we farm because of it you're
fighting against climate change yes here
in Napa Valley cab is king it's also
where researchers are trying to save it
with 11 different projects happening all
over the area you want to keep the wine
quality that's right we want to keep it
delicious and cost worthy of that $300
bottle Beck Stauffer vineyards is
investing tens of millions of dollars
partnering with UC Davis for the world's
most ambitious Cabernet Sauvignon
rootstock and clone trial vineyard
manager Clint Nelson and researcher
Concord Hall say the area has heated up
by nearly 2 degrees a year it may not
sound like much but bitter culturalist
say it's enough to eventually make
Cabernet grapes extinct we cannot just
say like oh we'll start thinking about
about 20 or 30 years from now you know
you have to you know take action now
what does it mean to this area that
you're doing this research we don't look
at this as just a northern California
trial or experiment we look at this as
an industry-wide trial UC Davis is using
shade Nets switching from horizontal to
vertical planning and various technology
to grow a better stronger grape you have
naysayers they might think we're going
too far
spending too much money doing it with
chasing things that won't turn up
researchers are testing a hundred
combinations but it will take at least
six
years to yield results like any fine
wine Beck Stauffer says it will take
time but the fate of one of America's
most famous valleys may hang in the
balance
we'll use that data not only to fight
climate change but in the best but
hopefully to improve the wine quality
that's the big deal after the break
we're heading for a planet far far away
despite its unwelcoming atmosphere 900
degree surface temperatures and sulfuric
acid rain storms to name just a few
NASA has its sights set on Venus as a
way to learn more about Earth the
Mariner spacecraft now on its way to
Venus is the most intricate instrument
in the history of space science just
three months after President Kennedy
made that speech in September 1962 NASA
completed the first successful flyby of
Venus a crucial moment in the Cold War
space race with the Soviet Union
ten years later Moscow responded when a
probe reached the surface of Venus the
first time any country successfully
landed on a different planets Venus was
hot in more ways than one
after a 15 month long cruise the
Magellan spacecraft will go into orbit
around Venus on August 10th in 1990
America's Magellan spacecraft beamed
back the best pictures yet showing a
hellish landscape where the average
surface temperature is just under 900
degrees but for the last three decades
almost nothing Venus is like a lost
world you know it has mists it's
shrouded in clouds and mystery but
there's a whole suite of instruments
that we would like to send there to
unveil what's beneath those clouds and
really discover those secrets here at
NASA's Jet Propulsion Laboratory in
Southern California sous mer car is the
number-one advocate for a new mission to
Venus when you look at this do you dream
of seeing someone there I dream of
seeing spacecraft there for the last
generation with Venus on the back burner
the main focus here has been on Mars
with another attention-grabbing mission
this summer
Mike Watkins is the labs director we met
him in the center of the universe
so-called because inside this room
NASA communicates with more spacecraft
at greater distances than any other
location in the world we talked to them
all we command them and we get their
data down through this room the lab
Watkins now runs was formed in the 1930s
focusing on rocket and jet technology
these days the Jet Propulsion Laboratory
no longer does any jet propulsion that
shift happened after JPL successfully
launched the first u.s. satellite in
1958 a response to Sputnik I think when
that happened we realized hey building
that satellite on top that rocket is the
cool part and so we kind of gave up on
rockets at that time and and and really
country done building spacecraft the
spacecraft Watkins and his team will
soon be tracking is a still unnamed
Rover the main focus of the Mars 2020
project we watched the final days of its
assembly before it's packed up in giant
crates and flown to Florida for July's
launch they're just about to lift this
thing up Ken Farley is the mission
project scientist at Mars 2020 his job
is about as daunting as it gets
somehow get samples that could show
signs of life from Mars back to earth
there are no samples that have ever come
back from Mars there are samples that
have come back from comets but this is a
whole different business and if you're
able to get that that's that's big
that's huge yep however the huge
challenges presented by Mars could pale
in comparison to the issues presented by
another trip to Venus it's been referred
to as the hell of the solar system it
can melt lead and there's tons of
sulfuric acid rain storms yes
why go Venus has so many lessons for
understanding you know rocky planets in
general and particularly understanding
earth scientists at NASA say Venus was
probably the first planet in our solar
system to have the
conditions to allow life to form but its
atmosphere is now at 97% carbon dioxide
a heat-trapping gas that's super heating
the planet finding out why that happened
could help us understand what's taking
place here on earth we can learn about
the very early processes that shape the
surface of the earth if we study what's
going on today on Venus and we have this
greenhouse it's incredibly intense on
Venus so it has tons of lessons for us
to take in as we try to prevent our
greenhouse from getting worse if you
look at Venus the Earth and Mars you see
three almost identical planets kind of
in similar locations they probably
started off similarly and they went
completely different directions
Mars turned into a desert with very thin
atmosphere
I mean it's turned into an oven with a
very thick atmosphere and we turned out
Goldilocks just just perfect and I think
scientists would like to understand
exactly how did that happen and what
drove that three planets three very
different directions but all with
important lessons as the team working in
the center of the universe tries to
answer the central scientific question
is there life out there I have to
believe there is it's pretty crazy to
think about it is it's also crazy to
think it's it's more in our reach now
than it's ever been before
attacks the new calendar that could
revolutionize the way we live and it
will tell you why mummies voice would
really sound like yes you heard that
we'll be right back
we all know leap years come once every
four years but do they need to and what
eliminating them save you money since
the beginning humankind has been
obsessed with tracking time and nearly
every civilization has tried to squeeze
that time into an accurate calendar but
for thousands of years we were missing
one crucial elements the leap year I
think that time is very confusing
sometimes what you have to think about
it Jackie Flaherty is an astrophysicist
at the American Museum of Natural
History's Hayden Planetarium in New York
City when people think about the day
February 29th what should they think
about we're placing a human construct
around what is an astronomical
phenomenon of the earth moving around
the Sun so it's kind of a celebration of
the fact that we'd really like to be
better timekeepers and we haven't quite
figured out how to do it quite correctly
yet the calendar we use includes leap
years because of how long it really
takes the earth to orbit the Sun which
is not 365 days it's about 365 and a
quarter people are fascinated by this
it's a fascinating topic
what could be more fascinating than how
we fit into time and our relationship
with time and our relationship with the
universe
Alexander Boxer is the author of a new
book a scheme of heaven which chronicles
the path that human inquiry took from
astrology to today's big data algorithms
including how we organize dates when
people think leap year today what should
they think of they should think that our
calendar is this fascinating product of
many civilizations each of whom have
tried to contribute a piece to make sure
we stay in sync with the seasons and the
leap year marked the end of an attempt
to sync up the calendar with the cycles
of the moon and an acceptance of the
calendar that was purely solar it was
the Egyptians who first made that leap
around 2500 BC but it wasn't until
Julius Caesar that the calendar began to
take the form we know today the Julian
calendar in 46 BC was the first at a
leap day every four years but it still
isn't quite right that led to the
Gregorian calendar which set the leap
year pattern we've used since the
sixteenth century but some think it's
high time for another big change you
guys have been working on this calendar
for how long decades and so far Mehta
enter dick Henry and Steve Hankey
professors at Johns Hopkins University
and the biggest current backers of a
brand new calendar one that eliminates
leap years and also standardizes the
days and weeks to always be the same
each year January 1 is always on a
Monday forever forever forever in
addition to starting every year on a
Monday the Hankey Henri permanent
calendar would also set your birthday
and the holidays to the same day of the
week every year except October 31st
which along with all Friday the 13th
would vanish in place of leap years
every 5 or 6 years an extra week is
inserted at the end of December sort of
an extended Christmas vacation
variations of this idea have been
discussed for more than a century but to
no avail
there's no such thing as a perfect
calendar you just think this is better
than what we have now ours is very close
to perfect we have current calendar
every year the thing jerks around by a
day or two and think how many people
around the world and sport schedules and
all these things that jump and jerk and
jerk around but aren't quirks and and
eccentricities part of the human
existence we could make things worse and
then you'd be happier well late they
cost they cost a lot though Henry &
Hankey's say their calendar is more
efficient because it makes school
calendars more predictable and evenly
divides business quarters which would
simplify financial calculations they say
it would save on average every person
five hundred and seventy five dollars a
year what you're saying is I'm not going
to get five hundred and seventy five
dollars in my pocket if this change
happens but it is gonna save both
workers and companies money and time
general efficiency it's real if it's
real why do you think it hasn't changed
until
people are interrupting it's very very
hard to change your thinking
besides ditching leap years Hankey and
Henry also one who eliminates time zones
it's already implemented for all the
airline pilots they use Greenwich Mean
Time and they better because if they're
flying across the Mississippi River they
don't want to change their watches by an
hour and then change their watches I
mean it's ludicrous I wish you guys got
passionate about this no look I'm stuck
on this planet with the rest of you and
I see us having a silly system here that
is costing us it may be costing us money
the question is whether a new calendar
would cost us some of our identity
either you can see the calendar as this
pristine sense of how the universe works
or you can see it as a human product
that really represents the contributions
of people over thousands of years to try
and incrementally improve our knowledge
of where we are in the universe does it
make sense to get rid of a leap year or
leap seconds calendar changes people I
think are resistant to because of what
it means from the infrastructure of how
we all live our lives the earth doesn't
really care what day you call it it
knows where it is it's going around the
Sun doing the thing it always does and I
really just want to know where is the
earth in reference to the Sun right now
with the help of a 3d printer scientists
recreated the sound of a 3000 year old
Egyptian priests voice Michelle Miller
tells us how with their moans groans and
screams Hollywood's mummies have always
given us chills
[Music]
researchers in England let us hear what
a real mummy sounds like that's the
voice of Nessie amoun an Egyptian priest
who lived 3,000 years ago
scientists were able to mimic Nessie I
moons voice by recreating his mouth and
vocal cords with the 3d printer it
allowed them to produce a single sound
nasiha moon was chosen for this research
because his remains were well preserved
during mummification and also because
there are inscriptions in his coffin
about his hope to speak again after
death a desire from the ancient world
fulfilled by modern technology
scientists hope to use someday the same
technology to recreate a living person's
voice more news and more stories like
this every week on CBS this morning
Saturday and you can find news 24/7
right here on CBS n featuring live
anchor coverage available for free
across all platforms I'm Jeff